hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Lauren gah
and I'm Jerry we're sitting so close
together and I'm suddenly aware that I
thought I didn't brush my teeth this
morning
Oh gross no what are you doing [ __ ] you
Godzilla's sitting next to me Lauren's
atomic I don't want to know okay so
today we're just gonna you know since
there's a lot of shoutouts we're just
gonna do some shout outs yeah hot dogs
yawn job I wanted to start off by
telling a little story that happened
with Lauren and I like Jerry hasn't
heard it yet no Cameron yeah we wanted
to see his reaction basically we went to
our Clyde cinemas right and it was
Lauren Marie and I withers they have
these like bobblehead toy cute there's a
table of them when you walk in and
that's like around me I was like a big
square head and they had like Joker and
they had oh they had all college dinner
it's a whole bunch of cool [ __ ] right
then I look to the left of me and
there's this family that's all looking
at the toys but one person in this
family is like a 15 year old kid and he
literally Hey I looked at my fate look
to my left and his face is exactly like
this like staring yeah and I was like
who is this guy like I don't recognize
and I thought it was so [ __ ] cool
then he immediately spots Lauren and
Maria and he goes Lauren go marry Carlos
man so then immediately we took a photo
with him because we wanted to keep it
for ourselves just like I want to take a
photo with this guy first person to
recognize us ever for Lauren myself and
Marie I know yeah good time so shout out
to Carlos for being an awesome fan dude
it's so strange well done yeah you were
dark it's like I heard your voice
alright let's do this [ __ ] you Alexander
but exactly baby ER but Teesta man you
wanted a shout-out broseph Joseph it's
like Alex and
xaviar yeah like Professor Xavier man Oh
that'd be cool if you're like Hispanic
Charles Xavier like you're a ball that's
manic dude yeah no I'd be really cool
but I'm in a Filipino like not be able
to use your legs
well I think reading minds I don't know
in the history exactly but I know that
there are a lot of like Spanish sounding
names in the Philippines because of like
Spanish settlements no historical facts
yeah or something brought to you by
Jerry anyway you might be Filipino so
good for Jerry you're so far off the
frame I suppose I know you just met you
I know I know you met Laura like a
memory that my breath smells bad okay
it's not you it's me like I can uncover
a rule being like hi I just met you
smash the camera back farther no I don't
believe in that
Batista Hispanic or Filipino Charles
how's it going buddy shout out shout out
David Navarro dude David Navarro that
sounds cool David Farrer
the guitar player yeah I think so you
subscribe to the channel used to be
married to Carmen Electra anyway Dave
Navarro dude you're huge thanks for
subscribing man I really appreciate your
support that you give us a job oh dude
that might change things for us
financially come on man you should
totally give us a show self hmm
now we're talking Aldo Romero oh now
you're not her and neither are you
but he said Sally and I do a great job
together what about us yeah although
what about Lauren and I and Jerry TV
can't exclude them
that's cool look at her we have great
chemistry good back and forth banter
but no I appreciate the compliment but I
don't
Anthony get to your essay yeah please
give me a shout out or I will get seized
I meant at the event Caesar and his
monkeys to go get you Caesar has monkeys
that's it's Planet of the Apes buddies
watch any of this Gutierrez
you need to learn how to spell but I
don't want you to take a bunch of eight
there eight there that's right he says
it oops I need to speak to Ceres our
Little Caesars so yeah that was not a
good smile I said okay I might use these
ridges like oh no no okay I don't know
gets here is I don't feel fat Gutierrez
dude you stay the [ __ ] man yes by the
way the Apes don't like to be called
monkeys if you've seen the movies they
really offended this is fact this is not
some made-up [ __ ] in a movie you better
watch yourself
have you ever : hey Bo monkey that [ __ ]
happens Jerry's energies always a little
lower when he's around a new person I
always noticed he just might like me as
close to me that's not God it's because
well because you need to have a mixture
of energies when you have more than two
people on screen well if you notice her
she's crazy
yeah you are and so that's how dynamics
work it's like you got a damn sorry
Jerry I thought we had a moment but
apparently we didn't oh it's okay I
don't mind I mean I'm just watching here
okay anyway thanks for helping me out
I'm not a youtuber said I like that
would appreciate if I leave a damn shout
out just say my name kasra and bam you
will be happy ha ha you must be happy
now you must be got the wrong we from it
back yeah
speak up huh what what if you talk loud
enough to your thinkin you know
frequency waves and oh yeah oh I got a
mansion someone real fast you set pastor
off he did a video or a tribute video to
us was like a 14 minute long video I
actually filmed the video of it and I
haven't done this in a long time I did a
reaction to it and I didn't leave the
mic on yep made that mistake again
sorry chief and I don't want to react to
something because then not natural and
it's not real so I wonder if I'm lying
but I appreciate it though man ya know
you mentioned you to know if I forgot to
turn the mic on I know but I'm just
saying he mentioned you to mention all
of us he mentioned like every single
person that's ever been yeah he's a big
fan yeah that was cool well Jake sees it
he comments all the time but we can't
comment back because of his accountant
for some reason well fix that [ __ ] he's
got like a Bible you know I think we
filed a restraining order on him or
something yeah anyway my TV a shard
DeLaGarza he said shout out this dick oh
excuse me is that fella say that name
George George Gordon Lord the poured hot
DeLaGarza
shelter the accents DeLaGarza yeah buddy
dick
you like to get that [ __ ] licked man you
have a lot of confidence maybe you're a
minor prick I'm done I was like that's
our consultant thanks he says slick I
stuck oh there you go girls Chuck down
that big dick and they get a little bit
sick he nicknamed his penis Nick like
Eric or Rick because you're so like
synonymous with dick stuff now that
people are like don't shout out me but
but shout out my dear to you that's like
sent us a picture of your penis
clattering don't you know that will
happen those families worn a picture of
your penis I'll do that do it for me
this is the internet it will happen I'm
gonna print out a million copies you're
gonna start getting everywhere so every
time you know
summer reaction video to you opening
with the dick in it we should take his
photo and post it everywhere across the
city actually that would be fun
yeah send us a dick pic I have never
seen this dick missing dick in this in
dick alright last one people nickel uh
yo yogi Patel yoga Patel like yogi
Tijuana
that name I know maybe are you giving
you a shout-out yogi let's find out oh
you should keep like no better know well
people like we request all the time well
stop doing that people yeah if you
request I'm so greedy if you'll get see
you be patient
I mean Chinese came out her there oh I'm
still back on the whole thing of like I
thought you had to earn a shot I know oh
wow no I like they gotta work for it
like if you demand it like over and over
and over again it's like whoa yeah
people aren't gonna buy the cow thing
get the milk pretty watch the channel if
they can get a shout-out for free
yogi potenti start charging for
shoutouts that would be fun um to make
it technique if you guys send this like
$5 little just like would you guys he's
gonna write you a rap you send us five
dollars if we set up some kind of paypal
would you pay a dollar per shot not if
this guy's giving them out for free no
dude
well yo ye you make me really happy
thanks yogi you like premium $2 for a
wrassle dollars are apps on photo right
two dollars start wrapping $5 per melody
seven dollars Lauren will show you your
tips
nope that's a little little $100 maybe
okay I have $100 yeah oh really
what this really happen there was this
an on-camera joke thing that we're doing
no there's none here is everything god
damn it anyway if you're new the channel
subscribe subscribe add yeah I'll dude
stop doing this to me we did a chain
reaction a snowpiercer and she went like
this
besides identities
what is snow desert
snowpiercer so it's about a snowman who
gets severe smoothness Noah's now I have
a feeling it's not what we did some
video where she just couldn't stop
laughing about a fan nation will that
will forever I remember he do she's like
what it's a nation of fans and I'm like
anything like and then she's like what a
this is the literal interpretation of
what it sounds like
that's hilarious she's crying
it's my makeup just everywhere I knew
yeah I'm gonna cut the camera now bye
guys